Recently, I renewed
my daughter's passport.
I had to go to the police
office three times.
Wait for hours in long queues.
Pay cash to the post office
and fill out tons
of forms of repetitive data.
And why?
Why did I waste so many hours of my life,
when just a few years ago,
I went to renew my own passport,
but since I need it immediately
for business reasons,
they proposed me the magic solution,
the fast track.
Once I demonstrated urgency
and paid the extra,
miracle, I got my passport
in five minutes.
Whenever I see a fast track,
I know there is a slow process,
and the slow process
often means a lot of wasted time.
But what is the impact of all this waste?
With simple calculations,
if every single person would waste
one of their 200 working days
to renew their passport every five years,
that's 0.1 percent of GDP.
In a country like Italy,
this is 2 billion euros of missed GDP,
and that’s only for passports.
Now imagine the impact of the waste
from ID and license requests,
work permits, tax declarations.
That's several points of GDP.
Solving this problem of waste
would have a greater impact
[than] what lawmakers achieve
through a typical financial act.
For the last 25 years,
I've analyzed how companies
create value for their customers,
and my research shows that, on average,
only five percent of labor
really creates value.
Five percent.
Can you imagine?
Most of our time is wasted.
Five minutes to issue
a passport is enough.
Companies must analyze
their value streams --
which is the sequence of activity
to create value for their customers --
and dig inside of each tiny activity,
questioning its purpose.
Which activity really matters
and what is just a legacy?
Are you wasting your labor
by overcontrolling,
executing redundant tasks
or fixing issues?
By rethinking the true
purpose of each task,
you will discover what is waste
and what is the real gold of your company,
the creation of value.
Here is an example.
What is the difference
between a bunch of ears of corn,
200 grams of flour and a pizza?
Organically, not much,
but they have different value.
Labor and know-how
can transform 20 cents of corn
into two euros of flour
and then into a 20-euro pizza.
We act like the economy
is this big, complicated thing.
But income, dividends,
the stock of the private equity
who owns the pizzeria,
their futures, forwards,
swaps, long and short options,
their cost of capital,
even the interest rate
of the central banks,
they are all derivatives of the real gold,
which is the human labor
which transformed cheaper corn
into expensive pizza.
Without that human labor,
none of it exists.
And when you add up all the value
created by the people in a country,
that's the GDP.
Unproductive labor
has no real impact on GDP.
So here is the exciting part.
If five percent of the labor
generates today the entire GDP,
imagine if we could increase it
just to 10 percent.
10 percent of your workday is what?
Forty-five minutes?
With these 45 minutes
we could double the GDP.
The challenge is first
to discover this real gold
because it is hidden
in an ocean of wasted labor.
Where do we look first?
Well, one of the best places to find waste
is in company's processes,
because they usually reflect
your company's past
more than its present or future.
These legacies
are massive waste generators.
[An] accountant matching
purchase orders with the invoices
is a legacy of offline transactions.
Submitting your time sheet online
is a legacy of punching into work
with a physical stamp.
My bank keeps sending me
account balances as a PDF,
so not only I waste my time by logging in,
downloading, opening the PDF,
but searching a specific transaction
is as difficult as it was
40 years ago, on paper.
Instead of carrying
these legacies into the future,
we should take a step back.
When a company analyzes each and every
activity of their value streams,
they should ask,
"Why am I doing this?
Is it still necessary?
Can I use today's technology
to make it more efficiently?"
Another consequence of this legacy
is that we spend
a large portion of our life
filling out the same useless data
over and over again.
To buy a plane ticket online,
some airline companies require
name, family name,
date of birth, ID number, expiration date,
country, gender,
with the distinction “Miss” and “Mrs.”
For what?
So someone with my same name
cannot use my ticket?
So my wife can't give her boarding pass
to another lady with her same name,
born on her same date,
but still unmarried,
so “Miss” and not “Mrs.“?
And today you shouldn't need the gender
in the passport or a ticket.
This is a legacy of a time
where men and women
didn't have the same rights.
So take a closer look
at the data you collect.
For each piece of information, consider
is it really necessary?
And do we already have it?
I remember one company's database showing
that 30 percent of their customers
were Afghan accountants.
What are the odds of that?
Why so many accountants from Afghanistan?
Obviously the first job listed
alphabetically in the drop-down menu
was accountant
and the first country was Afghanistan.
But what this tells me is that the company
didn't need this information,
and the customer didn't want
to spend the time filling it.
Another likely source of waste
is overcontrollership.
I worked with a company
whose procurement process
required 23 control checkpoints.
Now, how many of these 23 people
were looking closely, do you think?
And is it more likely that none of them
were paying careful attention,
assuming that at least one
of the other 22 were?
Too often overcontrollership
kills controllership
because it kills accountability.
I was listening
to a legal department complain
that in addition to checking
every contractor for compliance,
they were fixing grammar and spelling
because people drafting the contract
knew that the lawyer would fix it.
But come on, a lawyer to check spelling?
That's expensive, isn't it?
Instead, we should ask ourselves,
is that control check really necessary?
The answer is quite simple, just math.
Does it cost more to do the check
or to fix the mistake if it occurs?
This gets tricky
with very low probability,
very high cost of failure event.
People tend to overmitigate.
And in many cases
this creates even more problems.
In the UK, all commercial
fire alarm systems must be tested weekly,
and you often see
inside the building signs like,
“Fire test every Tuesday at 3pm.”
Now, if you were a criminal,
at what time and which day
would you commit your crime
without worrying too much about alarms?
Overmitigation
creates also a lot of waste.
First, because of false positives,
like a credit check
continuously blocking orders
with no real risk on payment.
Second, because of pure overprocessing.
My cinema app requires I change
my password every three months.
Six to eight letters,
uppercase, lowercase,
special signs, numbers.
Whenever I need to use it,
I spend ten minutes to log in.
But this is to avoid what?
That a hacker goes
to the cinema [in] my place?
If they go, I hope they enjoy the movie,
because the real risk
to the cinema company
is that I buy fewer tickets.
Logging in was so inconvenient
that I stopped using the app.
Companies should not sacrifice
their customer journey
for the sake of over-risk mitigation.
And by the way, making something
difficult for your customers,
it does not mean it'll be difficult
for a professional hacker.
More likely, it'll mean less sales
and less value created.
Altogether, these small changes
to your company's processes
can have a profound effect.
Entrepreneurs and managers
should refocus their priority
into the real gold.
Attract talent.
Help them grow, channel their energy
into the real value creation.
But there is another reason,
arguably more important.
A world with less waste and more time
dedicated to true value creation
is a more sustainable world,
where people can enjoy their work more.
Free from time-wasting
frustration and distraction,
they would have more time
with their family and friends.
They would enjoy more art,
more entertainment.
The real gold of our economy
is in your hands.
Please, for a better world,
strive to create more value.
Thank you.